[Music]
george RR martin the who was the mind
behind this show has told you i've heard
a secret about the show that nobody else
knows yes yes yeah he has and this was a
couple years ago when it was the first
time I met him and I was kind of
awestruck I was in there I was in I
liked my man and the first time he said
I've got something to tell you and he
leaned and he told me this secret he
said don't tell anybody so I'm not
telling anybody you're not telling
anybody who he'll tonight can he tell
you did he tell you who ends up on the
Iron Throne
did he could hub he could have Wow
that's fantastic that you know something
that people would just would die to know
but no one else well you know it but
you're not telling any I'd love to tell
you but let me let me tell you what's
going on here HBO have a person I don't
know where they are they're in the room
here so they have a sniper a Bharat v
you sniper rifle if I open my mouth here
tonight I'm out of here
you could you could be taken out as well
for asking the but everybody's wondering
is Jon Snow really dead can you tell us
that maybe not let's not do it
he's just looking to wingyee for the
shitty game sniper that's ready to take
you out right there yeah
how about this we have a clip from Game
of Thrones you know to set it up I tell
you one thing there aren't gonna be any
spoilers in it let's have a look I'm not
even sure I've seen it alright let's
take a look at this clip from Game of
Thrones I've never been much of a
fighter
holla juice for what you're about to see
you've got an exclusive there yeah
that's fantastic
you